Many people have contended that there is a
paradox of why should we tolerate intolerant
ideas.
And the answer is that we have to engage in
exploration and analysis of all ideas if we
are going to honestly and sincerely reach
our own conclusion as to which ideas we believe
to be correct and which ideas we believe other
people should adopt.
I go back to John Stewart Mills classic essay
called On Liberty in which he says here are
the reasons why we should listen to even ideas
that we believe to be completely wrong.
And as somebody who is advocating tolerance
for freedom even for the ideas that we hate,
I would say an idea that I would hate would
be an intolerance idea.
So here's the reason why I think I should
listen to that idea, paraphrasing Jon Stewart
Mills.
Number one, I may revise reviews after I listen
to that idea.
And I can give you a concrete example where
that actually happened thanks to the silver
lining of all of the protests on campus about
free speech.
Many students and faculty members even have
asserted that freedom of speech should not
be such a special important value in our society;
we should not tolerate freedom for ideas that
they consider to be dangerous ideas.
And quite frankly to me it had always seemed
so indisputably correct that we had to protect
freedom for all ideas that I never really
had grappled thoroughly with that contention.
I recently wrote a book on the subject and
in the process I had to articulate to myself
why I reached that conclusion and I did so
in a way that I persuaded myself, I hope that
means I was persuasive to my audience, and
I wouldn't of had to do that, I wouldn't have
enriched my own understanding of my long standing
position had I not been forced to grapple
with the exact opposite contention.
So, one possibility is that we will realize
that our original ideas were wrong or at least
could be improved, refined.
And another possibility is that we will be
reaffirmed in our adherence to our pre-existing
ideas, but we when do so, we will understand
them and appreciate them and articulate them
with much more depth and vibrancy when they
are the result, not just of unthinking reflexive
orthodoxy: "Oh that's what I've always believed
and that's what everybody else believes" but
when we are forced to really examine them.
And that forced examination comes through
contact and conflict with challenges and questions
and opposite ideas.